what do you think about yoshi banjos
talking about consciousness
and all of these kinds of concepts okay
um
i don't know what consciousness is
but uh
it's a good opener and to some extent a
lot of the things that are said about
consciousness remind me of
the questions people were asking
themselves in the 18th century or 17th
century when they discovered that
you know how the eye works and the fact
that the image at the back of the eye
was
upside down
right because you have a lens and and so
on your retina the image that forms is
an image of the world but it's upside
down how is it that you see right side
up
and you know with what we know today in
science you know we realize this
question doesn't make any sense
or or is kind of ridiculous in some way
right so i think a lot of what is said
about consciousness is of that nature
now that said there's a lot of really
smart people that
uh for whom i have a lot of respect who
are talking about this topic people like
uh david chalmers who is a colleague of
mine at nyu
um
i have kind of a
unorthodox folk
uh
speculative
hypothesis about consciousness so we
were talking about this audio world
model
and uh i think you know our entire
prefrontal cortex basically is
uh the engine for our world model
but when we are attending at a
particular situation
we're focused on that situation we
basically cannot attend to anything else
and that
seems to suggest
that we basically have only
one world model engine you know
pre-photo cortex
that engine is configurable to the
situation at hand so we are building a
box out of wood or we are you know
driving
down the highway playing chess we we we
basically have uh a single model of the
world that we configure into the
situation at hand
which is why we can only attend to one
task at a time
now if there is a task that we do
repeatedly
it it goes from the sort of deliberate
reasoning using model of the world and
prediction and perhaps something like
model predictive control which i was
talking about earlier
to something that is more subconscious
that becomes automatic so i don't know
if you've ever played against a chess
grandmaster
you know i get wiped out in you know 10
10 flights right
and you know i have to think about my
move for
you know like 15 minutes
and the person in front of me the
grandmaster you know would just like
react within seconds right uh
you know he doesn't need to
think about it that's become part of the
subconscious because you know it's
basically just
pattern recognition at this point
um
same you know you the first few hours
you drive a car you're really attentive
you can't do anything else and then
after 20-30 hours of practice 50 hours
you know a subconscious you can talk to
the person next to you you know things
like that right
unless the situation becomes
unpredictable and then you have to stop
talking
so that suggests you only have one model
in your head
and
it might suggest the idea that
consciousness basically is the module
that configures this world model of
yours you know you need to have some
sort of uh executive kind of overseer
that configures your work model for the
situation at hand
and that that leads to kind of the
really curious concept that
consciousness is not a consequence of
the power of our mind but of the
limitation of our brains
but because we have only one role model
we have to be conscious if we had as
many world models as
there are situations we encounter then
we could do all of them simultaneously
and we wouldn't need this sort of
executive control that we call
consciousness
yeah interesting and somehow maybe that
executive controller
i mean the hard problem of consciousness
there's some kind of chemicals in
biology that's creating a feeling
like it feels to experience some of
these things
that's kind of
like the hard question is
what the heck is that and why is that
useful maybe the more pragmatic question
why is it useful to feel like
this is really you experiencing this
versus just like information
being processed
um it could be just a very nice side
effect of um
of the way we evolved that's just very
useful to
to uh
feel a sense of uh ownership to the
decisions you make to the perceptions
you make to the model you're trying to
maintain like you own this thing
and it's the only one you got and if you
lose it it's going to really suck and so
you should really send the brain some
signals about it
you